THE RULES THE JULY IS HEREBY
COLD PLEASE BE ADVISED THAT
AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDINGS AND
FOR SOME TEAM MADE HAS ALSO
NO MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY CUNNINGHAM CARILLO
HERE LARA GRAYSON KAMLAGER-DOVE
YEAH MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS QUIRK
SILVA MOST HERE RIVAS WICKS
HERE WE HAVE WE HAVE A QUORUM
-- AND WE HAVE A CONSENT
AGENDA IS OUR MOTION ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA MOTION SECOND
MOVE ON THIS PARCEL SECOND BY
AS MATHIS OF MATTER SECTION
THIS CALL THE ROLL COOLEY HI
COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM CARILLO
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA I AGREE
SENATE RACE AND I KAMLAGER-DOVE
HI KAMLAGER-DOVE I THINK
TRYING LIKE MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS MATHIS I BURKE SILVA
QUIRK SILVA I REMOVED FROM
MOST AYE READERS RIVAS IRIX
BUSH HAS PASSED AND
THIS RULES BECAUSE OF
TERM THANK YOU VERY MUCH